okay guys I'm gonna stop sorry it's just
because but it's not now I'll run out of
time before we finish okay so you're
more than welcome to just keep on
plugging away at it especially if you
like these are the parts I'm fine but if
you like some of you I know you'll get
the first part you're like oh that's it
as I mentioned before whenever you get
one who's multi-part questions okay and
this is like a given resolve their like
prove this part one and then part two is
like do something else and so on okay
even if you can't get out part one if
you can't arrive at this result if they
give it to me the question you can still
use it for the subsequent months and
sometimes there's a lot of marks writing
on that okay so anyway I better start
alright so if you're fine with this part
then just keep working the later parts
but if you've got stuck here then pay
attention right now one pt that's the
tangent that we're interested in okay so
you've got this angle okay and so Peter
is so impatient okay and it's equation
will change based on what theories right
because if been a smaller one so that's
why PT as an equation it's dependent on
theta okay does that make sense so how
do we get at this equation well since
it's the in equation through this point
right T if I can find out what its
coordinates are right and find out to
find out its gradient then I can use
point great form right so how do I go
about finding what its coordinate our
first thing is it's the good circle okay
we first introduce this guy under tree
circular function is that kind of thing
it's why they called circular we
actually prove this result it's a
special result it uses the Pythagorean
identity
you remember that is they don't remember
so this is why we're doing revision now
okay I'm going to give you the
coordinates it's not enough just to say
that I will show you how to prove it
okay
but the coordinates are close dear
Sophia okay this is there any bells for
anyone okay how do we get there by the
way because it's the unit circle right
that's why you could say close square
which is the horizontal distance of
science curves the vertical distance
should equal the hypotenuse squared
which is 1 square cos square one
so how do I go about getting that it's
probably the easiest if you construct
for yourself a right angle triangle in
there somewhere so the one that I made
was so if I construct if I drop a so I'm
going to construct if you put stuff like
this on the diagram you can't just pop
it on and then I start working off and
you got to say what you're doing right
so I'd say construct TM perpendicular to
okay so there's my right angle now I can
say in that triangle there then you won
that I paid for and T right I can say
I've got some right-angled triangle
treat ratios right so in that triangle I
could say cos theta is adjacent on
hypotenuse right okay but boaty because
it's the unit circle is equal to Y so
therefore cos theta is just om right and
similarly sine theta is opposite
now om and Mt right there the X&Y
coordinates of T is heavy stuff our
linen yeah is my clothes and MT is how
fired that's the Sun right so therefore
T is correct
that's how I would get that result if
you could remember that the coordinates
of any point will be a circle our closet
or something
right now I've got coordinates so I've
got a point that line PT goes ooh what
was the other component I need I need
the the gradient of the line going
through there okay how I better I could
differentiate I could do it okay because
I know the equation of the unit turn
right so I would make why this subject
and differentiating so long okay
but there's an easier way right I can
use geometry rather than calculus
because I already know because it's
intention right the tangents
perpendicular to the 3ds at that point
right so if I could work out this
gradient overtake the gradient I'm after
is just the negative reciprocal event
right so what is the gradient alrighty
it's just rise over run right rise know
I could write that as potato but for the
sake of it because I'm gonna do some
work with this in a second I'm just
gonna leave it like that we have to
multiply stuff now so I might as well I
don't need to put it as the identity is
table
now that's ot right I can say therefore
there greater than I really want which
is Petey
for that reason okay so now I've got the
point and I've got the gradient so off
we go right equation P 2 is y minus y
coordinate which is equal to what's on
the right-hand side
no gradient yeah which is this X minus
sorry your x coordinate okay now don't
take any shortcuts at this point right
because you've already known what you
have to prove okay it's a foregone
conclusion so therefore all the marks
are dedicated to will show the steps
right don't go straight from here to
here even though it's true even though
you might be able to see it okay what
would you do from here yeah I multiplied
through my sign so that gives me this
and I might as well expand the
right-hand side while I'm at it
okay now can you see where it's going
right because you know what you're gonna
get on the right-hand side so take your
side squared over swap up with this X
cos theta and they'll give you sine
squared plus cos squared right which is
the undoing now with you
okay sweet any questions
oh right
find the length of BQ in terms of theta
BQ where's that that's up there in the
corner now it doesn't say hence in the
question but it really is a hint because
how do you do it how do we use part one
to do part two
yeah good I'm going to take this
equation which I just proved and what am
I gonna sub it to that good cuz that's
the line that it intersects with okay so
I don't think that's that complicated so
once you sub that in it's a pretty
straightforward sort of resort you
should get this okay now what's the next
step
it says part three show that the area of
the trapezium
now where's the trapezium it really
helps like it's seriously not having
extra colors in your exam because when
you got diagrams like this you've got to
do multiple things on they just help you
pilot the important information so the
trapeze in there after is this one big
hey there it is there
okay so you can see the two sides that
are parallel right so how do you like
out what is the area
huh times the perpendicular height right
times what yeah so you take your two
sides which are parallel to each other
you're gonna take this up okay in other
words it's really taking the average of
those two anymore okay
no have a look what have we got here
where is the height I'm just I agree
yeah it corresponds to this Lake Pia
right which is thankfully because the
incircle it's
what okay now we've already looked at
beach shoe it's one minus sine theta on
clothes there so now I want to work out
my final piece that I need for the area
that should please you I'm going to get
this length down here okay
now working out this like this just the
same as working out this like what do I
do I'm going to take this line PT and
I'm going to sub in the x-axis right
because that's how I get this corner and
because this is the origin once I have
it scored that's the distance okay
so again you substituted once you've got
that distance I think
one on constant is that what you get
it's at checkout
yeah I think that's all yeah it's
simplifies out quite nicely
okay so therefore to get the actual area
that what air is H on two times a plus B
which is this one minus sine theta plus
the other parallel so okay it's even the
same denominator so you can see you get
2 minus sine theta and this to this cos
theta we might as well just put them
together okay care almost there now part
four you've got to work out what the
minimum area is minimum so this is where
the calculus comes in and by the way
this is very typical the kind of
question you really get you're going to
build it all up and then the max speed
turns on okay so if this is our
expression for area I'm gonna have to
differentiate what rule should I use
after we try to avoid question right
because it's like oh can we do it by
chain rule that be much simpler in this
case I think probably there's no time
benefit because you actually have to
twist and turn this plane a lot to use
any other kind of rule okay
so even though it's a little awkward
because you know all of these things
they don't mix together quite very
nicely you could do that too on to cozy
up so that's one on across Dean up right
over here right inside you're gonna have
cycle your own clothes is ten there's
also next two so it's halftime okay so
what's the derivative of that yes s SEC
- I don't know it depends if you if you
memorize this result which we did
establish okay bigger now I actually
think doing this equation rule right one
of the benefits of it is it makes a
little obvious when you want to solve
this for zero why are you so in for zero
again good okay how about in the form
that I have it now I need to a little
bit of work to show you how I can solve
this Luiza sick feed all right what's
that that's one cause and this is a
cyber college so if I take out take out
a factor of safety
I've got that okay but I can do it again
right I actually could take out a sec
squared couldn't I right I'll take out
another one cuz here you left the sign
okay and since I'm taking out another
sec this just becomes now because SEC
squared is 1 over Chi square when I want
to solve this thing it's really on the
denominator right cos squared and
there's nothing you can make the devoted
and don't value that it can take which
makes the whole thing zero so I can
actually disregard it when I want to
find in the station so you can see
probably at this point right here when I
wanna fly the state your point is just
sine theta is equal to the half right so
what's your value of theta that you're
interested it's just pine seeds and from
there you just got to tidy it off test
it on either side to confirm you
wouldn't use second derivative because
first okay and that's it